uh so i went to music business school
and they talk about you guys like these
guys did it full independent
um but there's like this legend that
people talk about where they say icp
pick just a random town on the map and
it just ended up being this one random
place in texas and they went there
and just flooded it with posters and
flyers and to this day they have a real
big following in this one random town in
texas is there truth to that
yeah we we um because we um
we had detroit you know it it it seemed
like
we were just a local thing because we
were selling so many records in detroit
that we are trying to get a record deal
this is back in like 1995.
we were trying to get a record deal so
um jive records
they're not even around anymore it's
hard to believe they were such a huge
label
uh jive records came and signed us
and um and um but they only put us out
like in
in michigan basically we you know we're
selling like 80 000
um units in in the in the detroit area
and so basically they signed us and just
we're selling that and taking all the
money you know what i mean but they
weren't really working the record
anywhere
else so we threw a dart at a
a map of america and it landed on dallas
texas
and we we we [ __ ] we
took we took we bought three vans and we
wrapped them
with our album cover and all that and we
put fat rims on it and
put sounds in them and we drove the vans
to and we got samplers of the album we
bought
[ __ ] 100 000 samplers and flyers and
posters
and we basically moved to dallas and we
just
concentrated on dallas texas like
everything we had
we just pumped dallas texas every day at
three o'clock
those vans would be at three different
high schools in the dallas area
handing out samplers to all the kids
coming out you know
just handing out free samples everybody
you know and uh
we go to all the record stores we go
down to deep ellum where all the
clubs were at night we'd hand out
samplers everybody
going to all the bars and clubs and you
know and um
man next thing you know we had two
markets we had detroit and dallas you
know it worked
and it it was it was our way of proven
to the label
man all you gotta do is work it you know
it's not they thought it was like a
local thing the clown [ __ ] they didn't
understand they thought
oh it's some weird detroit thing because
if you look at the history of detroit
kiss detroit was one of the first cities
they were successful in
you know alice cooper's from detroit
with with his
crazy paint and all that i mean
detroit's always been like a
a weird place when it comes to painted
faces and showmanship you know what i
mean
and um so i think in the beginning the
record label thought we were just
a detroit thing happening you know but
we wanted to prove we could we could hit
anywhere
if if attention was given to it you know
and uh we did we proved it you know but
we didn't really care at that point we
had
we had started to build our foundation
ourselves
and pretty much by the time we ended up
signing the record deal
we wish we hadn't you know what i mean
we built our label up so big
there wasn't much they could do for us
anyway you know what i mean
[ __ ] yeah start to answer your question
paul it sounds like it's 100
true sounds like it yeah i was always
curious man i'm so glad to hear it from
you that's awesome
yeah dude